back here on the rich housing show
fantastic
back here on nbc sports on peacock nbc
sports audio 66m channel 85. having a
lot of fun in the commercial break
it's like only things that people who
live
with the host of nfl honors it's gonna
be airing live thursday nine eastern on
abc simulcast on espn plus and nfl
network the host of it for a second time
thrilled to have back here on the show
keegan michael key how are you sir rich
i'm great i'm great you know it's nice
to start the interview with giggles you
know what it's great to just start
anything with you and start anything
with google i know and it all started
with you sitting down here and saying
because you're a lions guy yeah that
this super bowl your super bowl adjacent
we're super bowl adjacent it was it was
l l you know you know
yeah she said well you're i i mean at
least honey you're super bowl adjacent
it sounds like i'm stealing that
and using that yes but yes i am i have i
am a lions fan and have been since i was
a child but i think i i've always been a
huge matt stafford fan always i i just
think i think he's a quality performer i
also by the way
matt stafford this maybe this is a hot
take i think is i think is a first
ballot hall of famer well there is a
sense that if he wins if he hoists this
trophy sits between us right now
on uh sunday night that that's that's
what's going to happen that would be a
shoe-in he'll if he doesn't win he he
could still be or a second ballot but i
think that he's i i just think that he
has the gift he's always had the gift
and really great he's always had great
touch great pocket presence you know
hustles when he runs out of the pocket i
mean i've seen the guy we've seen the
guy get injured big time big time and
then get up and keep playing and the
respect and admiration he has from other
players is is
you know
undeniable so i really i'm just so happy
for him i really am and he was such a
great ambassador for detroit i mean you
know and what did he know he's this kid
coming from georgia and texas and
georgia what did he know and he really
embraced that town he was wonderful we
made a video with him a few years ago
when uh elle and i were working um
um
l of course is my as my producing
partner and my writing partner and my
comedy partner and my wife lovely person
yes funny very funny very
very funny person super funny yes and so
we she we wrote a video for the of where
i was doing the a pro bowl um uh uh
campaign for the nfl and we were doing
it with the lions and and matt was just
great they were all great but he was he
was really just focused it i just think
he's great well i mean it's interesting
that you uh say that you're super bowl
adjacent because you're a lions fan
interestingly enough we had megatron
himself on this program friday really
yes and i asked him keegan michael key i
asked him that if matthew stafford wins
the super bowl
on sunday night for the los angeles rams
does he in a way
think that by the way we're back here in
our terrestrial radio network keegan
michael key here i'm saying that i asked
megatron on friday if stafford hoists
the trophy on sunday night do you feel
like
he's kind of winning it with you for you
that you're he's representing you in the
lines he said damn straight
oh a very emphatic answer actually he
cut me off he saw where i was going with
my meandering question did he really
said damn straight damn straight i i
feel like it's for everybody i think
it's for a couple of generations of
liars i'm talking like you know nick
fairley and robert porche and johnny
morton nice names i love these names
let's take it all the way back to my man
eddie murray i mean it's like he was the
best weapon
agree with calvin's sentiment damn
straight detroit will take it i think
we'll there'll be much celebrating in
detroit uh um that may not be
anticipated from other people across our
nation but we will be very happy well
wouldn't it be fitting ironic i don't
know what's the proper word if a guy kid
from ohio reigns on the state of
michigan's parade football laws that
would be ironic that would be uh that
would be ironic yeah sort of i don't
know like i don't know if alanis
morissette would write a song
it's a about that
wordy you know it's like rain on your
super sunday or something but uh that
kid is unbelievable yeah he's this kid
he's him and i feel like he's going to
be a generational talent and like um
what did mahomes say to him at the end
of the game he said
i'm sorry he said to josh allen yeah uh
he said to josh allen you know we're
going to be doing this a lot yeah and
i'm like yeah but you guys may be doing
it a lot and still facing this kid i i i
watching him still play watching him
still play i should say yeah watching
her watching him still playing right i
just
i i really have this feeling in my gut
that that burrow is going to be a
generational talent yeah he's already
he's pretty funny too have you heard
some of his lines oh yeah and and his
twitter's pretty strong yeah he's really
he's really good yeah he said you know
like he wore he came looking like the
rock from back in the old 80s or
whatever
circa 94 yeah right
without the fanny pack and they asked
him if it was real and he goes i make
too much money for this to be fake i
know yeah and with the deadpan with a
really solid deadpan this kid's got and
a lot i mean he's oozing confidence this
is gonna be a good game this is gonna
i'm really really excited about this
game keegan michael key right here on
the rich eisen show nfl honors tomorrow
night your second go around right here
what uh what can you what can you reveal
preview you're working you're still
honing
we're still honing
we've got some great stuff cooked up for
this show we really really do um again
um i have my secret weapon with me
elle's one of the head writers this year
and uh so you know we've got we've got a
really good staff and i'm trying to keep
everything under wraps because we've got
i think we've got some real humdingers
that are really gonna okay they're
really gonna work so i would i would
love to talk we could do a postmortem
i'll come back and do another interview
we'll take you anytime you you're free
okay andrea we're gonna do a post-mortem
lock that in okay very good i have other
ideas too
everything under wraps because it's
going to be it's going to be a really
really fun fun honor all right first
time you did it who did you meet for the
first time where you're like okay this
is it right they they had me do a bit
when i was sitting in the seats i was
sitting in between warren moon and joe
namath
i almost
i didn't know beforehand i think they
were like we could just sit over here
and that's it you know i'm just like i'm
in there no he's just like i knew it
because sometimes the rotation happens
like a person that something comes up
they can't do it somebody else is going
to do it right sure and i think i was
just preparing myself
for
either nameth or moon i didn't know it's
gonna get sandwiched between both of
them fantastic it was it was almost too
much for me and so i sat there and i was
like oh three two
you know it was it was really that that
was overwhelming for me to meet him and
you know who else i met at that one
who's that john stallworth
okay john stallworth right well you have
some pennsylvania roots too i do from
penn state
i went to penn state and i've also been
um i've also followed the steelers since
i was a kid because my father's best
friend was from pittsburgh so we grew up
in detroit and we would go to their
house down they lived on the block from
us and that's where we watched those
those dynastic super bowls so you had
some winning then as a kid there was
some winners
we did have some wins yes
and we had we had like two
we had two really
decent seasons when billy sims was there
and eric hipple was the quarterback i
know you just nobody was expecting to
hear the name eric here you gotta say it
you gotta you've gotta give a paw before
like you know like in the old days when
when summerall used to do the promo for
murder she wrote he would always
pronounce the comma like murder
she wrote you kind of have to go you
have to have to go at quarterback eric
hipple
you heard me right folks you heard me
right
because i went to when i went to the
university of michigan and my jets came
through with the joe must go joel walton
jets came to play the lions and the old
silver dome and daryl rodgers was
coaching
and both teams
when you can't use the word sucked you
can't just just you mean the absolute
epitome of ineptitude
the worst like imagine yes like yes if
there was a zero uh first round draft
pick it would whatever whatever whatever
is better than the first
and i remember going to the game and i
bought tickets and i got in and they're
like just choose any seat
like the old people like the old
people's express airline
wherever you want to go and they almost
made us pay like during the game like
whatever you want you know like coming
down the aisle with that with the credit
card machine the food to you
that's what it was like i've got nothing
else going on right
and it was you know the silver gnome was
one of the hugest places with a roof on
top of it ever ever and yeah it was that
place was cavernous i when i was a kid i
used to go see
pistons games where they would drape off
do you remember that curtain off the
pedestal is that the kelly trapuca error
you took the words out of my mouth i was
gonna say if we're gonna if we're gonna
utter the word eric
hipple right
why wouldn't we say
and two points for kelly
trapuca
kelly trapuca yeah wow yeah that's the
days man uh we're taking see i love that
you went to school in ann arbor oh yeah
because that hey how about this name
let's do some names okay here we go
tishmanga
bianca batuca that's your guy right tj
that's your guy i wore his jersey in a
movie once though
just say why don't you just say yes to
that one
i was in remember i told you i was in
just married with ashley kutcher
brittany murphy there was a beach
football scene and i wore a batooca
jersey who gave you the bianca patooka
jersey i had i used to work at foot
locker back in the day
by the way if you've ever you know been
to a pittsburgh foot locker
i don't if we put him in a referee
jersey would you say oh now i recognize
anybody i remember that one time it was
bald i didn't have the locks back
you're the clean shame yeah it was
probably like 20 pounds lighter too i
know i got you but i might still
remember it tj just just the essence
the man just the command
at state college you know we might run
into each other somewhere in state
college yeah maybe
each other at you know the diner
the atherton room for the griddle
for mario and luigi's i'm sorry i'm
dropping deep cuts
everybody from 30 years ago nothing's
nothing's deeper than eric hipple
you will not get deeper than that by the
way eric hipple led the nfl on
completion percentage in 1986. wow
that's a line on your resume i would
never want
63 percent complete
in 86 yeah how about that all right okay
okay i'll take this
here on the rich eisen show well you as
a die hard football fan and a now
two-time host of nfl honors yes you you
know the best story is a redemption
story correct it's a it's always always
always yes so make sure it's the gas
that makes the engine of our sport go
correct so uh we're about to have one
here oh and it involves you oh dear last
time you were here i don't know you
you've appeared on many shows and had
many many moments uh but last time you
were here uh we played the game start
bench cut where we give you three
choices you have to start one bench one
cut one yeah and then we gave you one
specific uh version of it in which mike
del tufo after he had already claimed on
the show and to you he was the bill
walsh of audio he did he said the bill
walsh of audio yes you really set it up
there buddy i did and then botched the
playing of said audio right we could
we'd never heard the audio
that's correct which makes him the daryl
rodgers of audio
[Laughter]
this is
great depths so at any rate so uh we'd
like to play one more version of start
bench cut with you yeah that also
includes some audio so he can finish up
strong and redeem it i want that for you
i want this redemption story to end with
a hap
with a happy ending so here we go here's
another version of start bench cut okay
three items for uh keegan michael key
the host of nfl honors let's hit it
right here time start stop
sit down and be quiet
all right we're off to the first uh
we're off to a roaring start i heard
that and i saw it right
production value
from here yes we can yes we are we've
got momentum okay first one for you
keegan michael yes your uh outstanding
podcast history of sketch comedy we all
enjoyed it thank you very much thank you
so uh start bench cut we've given you
three
uh of the some of the best sketch uh
comedy sketches okay
so start bench cut first one is who's on
first yep the monty python dead parrot
sketch
or the snl cowbell sketch these are just
three that we just pulled out okay start
one bench one
cut one keegan michael key okay gotcha
all right i'm going to start
i'm going to start the classic i think
we've got to start with the veteran okay
we're going to start with who's on first
okay first just on patter alone uh one
of the greatest double acts of all time
uh certainly in in in you know
living memory yes and uh then okay so
now it's the toss-up between home and a
bench and who i'm gonna cut this is it
oh boy this is a tough one
i think i think i'm gonna have
it's cowbell and dead parrot yes that's
your choices you have to yeah yeah cut
one i'm going to i'm going to i'm going
to bench dead parrot okay and i'm going
to cut cowbell
cowbell has a very strong middle
but you know the hardest part of a
sketch is always the blow it's always
the button or the end yes not the
strongest ending yes a great great
middle long long middle great ending
dead parrot better better ending so
that's my i'm gonna there you go there
you go that's the and i love breaking
down comedy like that is a science and
um so the sketch technically needed a
little more cowbell
because i got a fever
it's got a prescription that is one of
the best lines okay because i don't want
to cut it's very talented very gifted
player but you got to cut somebody
exactly that's what that's the whole
part of this endeavor it's very
difficult all right so obviously uh you
and jordan peel a phenomenal uh team for
all those years and one of your best
sketches and we talked about it before
is certainly for this week for football
where the players are announcing their
names yes on a monday night football and
you said jordan once came with a list of
like four they just came to work and
just set like five pages in front of me
with all of these names written out he
just hit sp it was just like you just
chose which ones were the best
and it was almost all of them perfectly
to that script i was like this is this
is amazing and i think i said i wouldn't
cut any of them
and the only thing i added was dan smith
i said we just need a white guy
and he has to go to byu i love it it's
so funny okay so we have come up with
three names from the 60s and 70s of
actual players and you need to start one
bench one and cut one as to which ones
could have made this list copy it copy
that okay here we go here we go
this is real here here we go here we go
here we go uh i wrote this down the
first name on is
dick shiner
okay oh dick shiner dick shiner was an
11-year veteran quarterback with six
different teams so dick scheiner was a
journeyman okay look even in dick
scheiner's card like he's literally
wearing a brown's uniform and there's a
series
all over the place
speaking of the browns there's a wide
receiver played six years in the league
all with the browns his name was fair
hooker
fair hooker that is his name okay i i i
had to re-read that a couple of times am
i reading that right
fair hooker fair hooker and then on the
left on your screen was one year he was
a one-hit wonder unfortunately uh wonder
mons a defensive back we have his card
from the university of nebraska he
played one year in the league in 1976
his real name his full name in case
you're wondering i am wondering
wonderful terrific mons jr okay
not to calvin johnson you but we're
clearly starting
wonderful
terrific junior junior that's right that
was his name so then i guess you have to
bench
dick shiner
we're benching fair hook fair hooker
we're we're benching fair hooker yeah
we're cutting dick shiner
because the fair hooker fair hooker
that's it's really
i don't it's what we're all looking for
overwhelmed with the amount of jokes
that i could come up with
that i can't even spit one out
my man's name
yes
so but there's two ways to take that
either either this monetarily works out
for everyone or just adequate hooker
he did okay
that's right this could go either
we have three of the most famous nfl
films wired for sound
cuts oh this is great okay okay uh mike
del two folks just play play uh play the
first one go what the hell's going on
out here
you heard that thanksgiving i heard that
i don't know it's vince lombardi what
the hell is this little party that's
correct it might have been that game but
it's vince lombardi sorry go go go uh
pump it in there baby just keep
matriculating the ball down the field
boys that's hank's favorite
okay and then the last one is shannon
sharp going we need as many men as you
can fare because we are killing the
patriots so call the dogs off send the
national guard please
that need emergency help yeah okay so
those are the first of all you heard
them all yes fantastic okay okay i heard
mike
well done
so those are three choices you must
start one bench one and cut one can you
return to the music now mike is that
possible okay very good there you go so
go for it okay here's my thing
i'm already torn on the start i am big
fan of a 50 cent word i really love a 50
cent word
but the pithiness and cleverness of
calling the national guard because no
one knew that was coming in the line
it's you got a great zinger talk about a
good blow for a sketch yes
i have to as a sketch artist yes sir i
have to i have to start the person who
put a great button on the end of their
sketch so that's shannon sharp there you
go we're starting him yes i can't
believe i'm literally about to do this
next to this trophy i'm sitting next to
this trophy and i'm literally about to
do this
everybody forgive me wow
i have to bench matriculate down the
field and i have to cut what the hell is
going on out there
i just caught vince lombardi next to the
trophy next to the trophy after i
apologize to the nfl i apologize to the
tiffany company
i apologize
you get that
i apologize
to everybody who works at the rich eisen
show
i apologize to my driver who has to get
me to rehearsal as fast as possible so i
don't get mobbed outside by his
football historians
whoever else i'm missing somebody i
apologize to olivia my makeup artist
eric kipple you're forgetting
[Music]
my sincerest apologies
my hey but come on he said matriculating
that's a good
just keep matriculating the ball down
the field because he's wearing a sport
coat with the chiefs crest patch on it
right
i mean it was just great it was just
charming
yeah
this was amazing as i expected yes
[Applause]
he's been sweating bullets literally
you're good you're good i never even
remembered the lines from the predator
one
because i didn't i didn't hear them here
i didn't hear them
apparently wonderful mons cfl legend oh
really
and did he play for the eskimos the
edmonton eskimos i don't know someone
named jerkface loser just kidding
i'm starting jerkface
what school did he go to yeah
um i don't even know if they
they went away and then came back
like that ottawa was a team then they
weren't a team another team again that's
amazing you're the man i just i i
literally my side's hurt every time you
come here it's always it's always
a distinct pleasure thank you right back
at you keegan michael key everybody
watch nfl honors again airing live
tomorrow night thursday night nine
eastern on abc simulcast on espn espn
plus and nfl network either man thanks
thank you rich hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here